sur le tarmac de l'aéroport ben gourion
arrive des centaines de milliers de
nouvelles doses du vaccin pfizer ventech
c'est un grand jour pour l'état d'israël
avec une énorme livraison dans un avion
qui revient de l'opération retour à la
vie un avion plein de vaccins
d'encouragement j'ai conclu avec mon ami
le pdg de pfizer albert bourla que les
livraisons allaient arriver les unes
après les autres et que nous aurions
terminé la vaccination des plus de 16
ans au cours du mois de mars
en effet cet avion n'est pas le premier
à apporter des doses du vaccin contre le
coc vie 19 déjà 72 % des plus de 60 ans
ont été vaccinés et dès cette semaine ce
sera le tour des 50 à 60 ans pour
expliquer le succès de cette campagne de
vaccination
il y a tout d'abord l'anticipation dans
la course au vaccin
israël a toujours été en pole position
dès le mois de juin l'état hébreu
commandes est déjà des vaccins à modern
à un contrat au prix fort selon les
médias locaux
25 euros la dose contre 12 à 15 euros en
europe
il y a aussi la logistique petit pays
peuplé de moins de 10 millions
d'habitants il dispose de quatre régimes
de sécurité sociale
chaque caisse s'est très vite rapproché
de chacun de ses patients
tous les gens de plus de 60 ans ont
ainsi reçu un sms chez eux leur
demandant de venir se faire vacciner ou
prendre rendez vous si les personnes ne
s'inscrivait pas il recevait un coup de
fil de la part des centres de
vaccination
tout se passe bien les gens arrivent
avec leurs documents et nous n'avons eu
aucun problème majeur jusqu'à présent
pour éviter le gâchis et s'il reste des
doses en fin de journée il existe même
une liste d'attentes pour les personnes
volontaires mais pas prioritaire
et alors que seul un quart de la
population ne souhaite pas se faire
vacciner une défiance minimes
le gouvernement a tout de même misé sur
la communication
cette technique montrer l'exemple
responsables politiques vedettes du show
biz et présentateur de télévision se
sont fait vacciner face caméra à
commencer par le premier ministre
benjamin netanyahu
ce samedi il recevait d'ailleurs cette
deuxième dose de vaccin seul bémol
l'état hébreu n'a pour le moment rien
prévu pour les territoires palestiniens
qu'il occupe